Président Madame Le Pen ayant rendu
hommage au combat des députés des
républicains sur le prix du fioul je
voudrais madame le Premier ministre vous
interrogez sur le prix de l'électricité
pour les entrepreneurs français
la France produit de l'électricité
nucléaire notamment à 50 euros le
mégawattheure et pourtant nos
entreprises doivent actuellement se
fournir avec des contrats à 600 700
euros le mégawattheure pourquoi à cause
d'un marché européen devenu totalement
absurde qui lit le prix de l'électricité
et le prix du gaz monsieur Poutine a
créé une crise du gaz en Europe l'Europe
s'est inventée une crise de
l'électricité
la situation est aujourd'hui intenable
pour la plupart de nos de nos
entreprises on voit avec ces
boulangeries qui ferment en ce moment
par dizaines tous ces artisans qui nous
disent qu'ils ne passeront pas l'hiver
et puis ces entreprises industrielles
qui sont conduites à arrêter purement et
simplement leurs production après trois
années de crise cette situation crée de
véritables drames et situation de
détresse humaine alors aujourd'hui les
mécanismes de protection qu'ils soient
nationaux ou qu'il soit européen je
pense aux décisions du dernier conseil
de vendredi dernier seront quasiment
inopérantes en France et en tout cas
très largement insuffisante on est très
loin des 200 milliards que le
gouvernement allemand va donner à ces
entrepreneurs pourtant il y a des pays
qui s'en sortent je pense à l'Espagne au
Portugal ou le prix de l'électricité est
inférieur à 200 euros parce qu'ils ont
réussi à faire reconnaître une exception
ibérique pourquoi ce qui est possible en
Espagne ne l'est pas en France parce que
me répondrez-vous grâce à la pitoyable
gestion du parc nucléaire la France est
devenue aujourd'hui un mendiant
énergétique mais nous produisons encore
80% de notre électricité et cette
électricité ne vaut pas Madame le
Premier ministre 500 euros de
mégawattheure qu'attendez-vous pour
prendre des mesures d'urgence pour nos
entreprises